what's up future fam donuts donation you
know what time it is it's time to do
another session
of logo therapy hey zimri mayfield if
you're hearing this message or your
friend
friend of zimmery we want you on the
show we try to reach out to you but for
whatever reason you're just
dissing us right now and without further
ado let's just jump into my deck
you guys know what time it is we're
doing two logos from two designers today
and back with us two by two first up is
mart beeman's
you guys he has a new studio it's called
studio opmars the man from mars the
martian himself from the netherlands
and the man whose resting face is very
angry
that is him and then of course we have
aguin davier loreto
all the way from monterey mexico and
this is his work you guys are very
familiar with it
let's get right into it now i don't even
know how to say this person's name
martial you're gonna have to help me out
is it blodgett matthew stephen i think
so
okay we'll go with that and here's this
logo i don't even know what this is is
this
guild design or three design or i think
it's ill design
ill design ill design that's what i went
with so
okay so we have some issues already off
the top
this is going to be a fascinating one so
without further ado mart
take it over all right man am i sharing
my screen
yeah share your screen okay
i think i'm already sharing my screen so
i'm just starting out the video
um show my process real quick okay
that's what i usually do when i um
want to create a new logo i just go on
the internet and search for some
inspiration so i first made a mood board
with some
stuff that has already been done before
making some notes here
something i'm going to change for
example it's from my opinion way too
busy i don't really like typography and
the shadow effect so
that's what i'm going to change about it
and i'm just on the right side you will
see
the mood what i created just to get a
bit of inspiration because i didn't
really draw a unicorn before so okay
that was new for me aaron let's punch
into the full screen please
it's hard to see because the drawing is
sold no no you don't do anything mark
don't worry
aaron's gonna take care of it okay keep
talking you're drawing my hair
the unicorn hey i'm just trying a couple
of different shapes and
one of my first ideas was to use the
word ill
inside the symbol that's interesting so
that's what i'm going for here
so when you lose when you don't use the
typography then you can still use the
symbol
on its own and it still seriously oh so
it wasn't the basic
yeah so you're sketching in photoshop
right now
yeah yeah that's always my preferred
method
it's because it goes really fast and you
can easily duplicate and change things
well it's due it's fast for some people
not fast for others but i know yeah
that when you did this other people were
influenced by this and they started
sketching in photoshop as well so that
was cool
cool so actually the last time someone
from the audience they asked me to focus
a bit more on the quitting system so
that's what i did this time i
focused a lot on the symbol itself and
not so much in the topography
so that's what we got into later so
you're also
fitting the the animal into a square
trying to make it as
dense as possible right yeah just so
that it becomes
like nothing loose so it becomes solid
symbol
so i'm just trying out a couple of
things here just with the different uh
main stuff like that just really quickly
find out
some basic ideas and just refining the
sketch as we go
so this is the part where i'm adding gym
up geometry so basic circles and just
straight lines so that the sketch
becomes a bit cleaner
so i just i could quickly forward this a
bit because it's
a lot of the same mm-hmm so you're still
in photoshop right
yeah okay i see so i really like to
create a really clean sketch before i go
into illustrator so that i already know
what it's going to look like in the end
yeah and then i just
use illustrator to clean it up and
create effective vowel from it
now sometimes when you're sorry go ahead
sometimes when your sketch is not that
clean yeah can you can stumble onto
problems in illustrator so that's why i
like to get everything perfect in
photoshop and then
go into vodka in illustrator
and trace says oh i like that idea
who said that andrea andre hey if you
guys aren't sure whose voice that is
it's jonah's voice for the first time
i don't hear him very often because
today on today's episode aaron is back
and he's editing he's not fired he's
still here and he's editing the live
stream
and joan has taken over usually what
mark does in terms of monitoring
comments so if you guys have questions
or comments
be sure you drop them in the comment
section below
there that's that's how you know it's
below not up there
good job good job okay let's keep going
okay let's keep watching martier
so yeah this is just basically trying
out some variations in terms of how
thick i want the
the lines to be so i got a few with a
few thin ones and a few pick ones and
i just went forward a bit mm-hmm so this
one i had the orange because
it's not the unicorn so
just see it's also pretty basic
just using uh lines that can help you to
create a clean symbol
yep in case you guys are wondering how
is it that mark can work so
fast he's not it's a time lapse video
you guys it looks like he's actually
working on it right now in real time and
he's an animal
i mean he is an animal a designed beast
himself but this is sped up
yeah this was about a total of three
hours i think
three hours like the whole video it's
put into
13 minutes but i'm speeding in the video
of the spill no
are you using the fill the the bucket
paint fill tool or you just call it
sometimes sometimes yeah okay when i'm
lazy
or smarter who knows yeah i mean this
this doesn't really have to look that
good
it's just to get an idea of how thick i
want the strokes to be and
what the proportions are going to be in
a in the final version yeah
i like seeing your process like this
because a lot of people rush to
vectorize it
and they're making all kinds of weird
decisions right because
to do it like this you're working really
fast you can try many ideas you're
iterating really quickly and you're
exploring things
and when you take a take a look back
you'll see how many different versions
or iterations and
the different decisions that mart's make
making on these things so it's nice to
see this
and i think it's also when i don't do
this then i tend to not
try everything that's possible and when
i do this like these random ideas pop
into your head and then
you just have to try them out so you can
try them out real quickly in photoshop
and you
can you can see right away if it works
or not so
and the fact that passover is very time
consuming so that's why i doing in
photoshop
so as you're working on drawing one idea
or ideas for another thing popping in
your head so you want to finish this one
work on the next one is that how that
works yeah
yeah basically cool i'm the same way
so yeah just go forward a little bit
here
this is why i'm adding the typography
and i decided to keep it really simple
and wanted to
use the same stylus in the in the symbol
so it also has the same
thickness in the letters and the l is
also spelled the same way
so that looks consistent with the with
the symbol
i think i spend about 25 percent of the
time
on the typography and the rest of all i
spend on the on the symbol because the
symbol was way more important to me
in this case because last time people
focus asked me to focus a bit more on
the gridding so that's why
i decided to go focus more on the on the
symbol itself instead of the topography
i think oh and you're drawing all these
things in photoshop
yeah wow
but with guidelines so i use the
guidelines to get the proportions right
like these just trying out if it's
serif fonts will work or not i didn't
really like the serif font here
i think the middle one is the one that i
worked with
so this is where i save this uh jeep
back and then go into illustrator and
clean it up okay you can fast forward to
illustrator
it looks like you made one more tweak
before you brought it back into
illustrator
i am done i got two variations
one is the mains going up and one is the
mains going like this i wasn't really
sure which one i was going to use yet
so decided to bring them both in
so now as you can see i'm um actually
putting the lines exactly on the
on the grid of illustrator so i can
really easily create these
helping lines to make the final shape of
the symbol
and for everybody that's watching how
did you make those circles equidistant
from each other
um i got the snap to grid on in adobe
illustrator
and i thought as you can see there's
these squares here can you can people
see my mouse i can see it yeah
yeah so there's these these squares here
and that's what i'm using to count
um how many steps are going to be
between the lines so it's the same for
the circles here
as you can see the steps here you go
through the steps between the lines
so let's make that makes it so that the
symbol is very balanced
i see so the diagonal lines are also on
that same grid
yeah snap to grid okay
you are definitely living up to the
whole logo gridding
promise this time yeah very good
are you using pathbinder
no i think it's this bucket because i
like to keep the shapes intact so just
i always um copy and paste the lines on
the new layer then i
make the lines go away and then i use
the bucket to fill in the
space that i want to use for the symbol
um okay
that's a good tip that's it preserves
the guides yeah preserve the guides
appreciate them
i guess there's like 10 or 20 ways to do
it but it's just the way that
i got used to it you know so yeah well
your way's the best way for you
it's always that way there's a thousand
ways to do something
mm-hmm
so in the final version i decided to
turn the
symbol 45 degrees
now i saw you playing that throughout
the sketching phase what was going on in
your mind in terms of it being
square versus rotated at 45 degree
um because i knew that there was going
to be typography on the right side of it
and when i ended like um on horizontal
line
i didn't really like the way the horn of
the unicorn was
floating above the typography so this
way it's
more balanced towards the right and at
first i was
pretty bothered by the by the arnold
unicorn actually because
it's like sticking it's the only part
that's sticking out of the out of the
square
but i started to like it more and more
because
it's the part about the unicorn that
makes the unicorn so i don't really mind
it sticking out because it's the thing
that
attracts your eyes at first and then you
see the rest of the shape and then you
know oh it's unicorn
so
i'm curious when you go to draw the s
how you're going to draw the s
there's actually a letter i like last i
like the lace so
but as i said i didn't spend that much
time on the
on the typography itself this time
mostly on the symbol
but i still think the typography works
with the symbol
but if this was for a client i might
have refined it a bit more
what are these shapes that you're
drawing here
uh i'm just using them as guidelines to
create the letters so that they are also
the
same thickness as the is the
symbol itself
so yeah that's the final and then i just
uh
like last time i also prepared some
just gonna quickly show it uh some
mock-ups okay
this is the final logo and this was the
criticism that i used to create that
the symbol some variations
and some vocabs nice that looks really
good as a sign
dang if that were a hang tag too that
would look really good ill design
well done
mm-hmm so this this is always what i do
to understand the logo of the clients
just to give them an
idea of somehow something look when it's
used in real life
so these are the final sketches so some
from the top left
to the bottom right it's like basically
my process in one picture
can we see the final lock up just um
black and white the the mark that you
created and the logo
yeah okay do you have one that's just
one we're just straight
so i can look at it and just stare at it
for a little bit and then this one
yeah that one the lower right yeah uh
okay
okay then hide all that other stuff
maybe
everyone's saying they love it it looks
so amazing so cool
it is really good we might not even need
to take the poll
it's pretty obvious the results of this
poll but we'll do it at the end when we
go
before and after okay there that's
beautiful let's look at this now let's
zoom in
so yeah i'm pretty satisfied with the
symbol itself but like i said
uh i like how the topography of this
part the ill
looks the same as here but i think this
part looks a bit unbalanced much
yes i agree no i don't have time or so
all right let's punch in aaron let's
punch in full screen let's take a look
at this
okay can you hide all that junk can you
tap and hide all your
garbage smart yeah okay let's go full
screen okay so
i'm looking at this and i think you're
right the mark looks really good i think
you've done a great job
i like the idea of integrating the
the ill part of the design into the
drawing of the horse itself
by the way this also shapes a little bit
as a d of the side
okay maybe i'll give you that one i'm
not sure that might be a little bit of a
stretch there
that's called designer bs
okay but i like the ill i like that i
also like
you tipping it to the side 45 because i
like the horse kind of looking
up versus charging down uh when you had
it leaning kind of on a horizontal
before
and i i think it's neat how you created
an interesting word mark with the ill so
that i see at least
two to three components that can be
turned into a pattern or a texture
if you rotate it like 90 degrees and you
can repeat that that would look really
cool
the part that is really needs a little
bit more love and i know you recognize
this already
is the design but for the sake of
learning i just want to talk to the
people on the academy future site
just to talk about this a little bit you
can see that there's some
inconsistencies in the letter form
mostly it's the width to me the n it
feels
really narrow relative to the d and also
we're trying to find repetition in the
design of the letter forms it almost
looks like they all come from a slightly
different universe
you also notice the g because of the way
it's cut and the way
um the stroke and the crossbar is drawn
it feels a little different than the d
and they need to feel
very similar right so mark's going to
work on this probably at some other
point in time in his life maybe who
knows
but that's really what we need to work
on yeah and then you'll share it with us
and we'll show everybody
now let's take a look at the before and
after let's get those next side to side
a and b so the audience can vote
do you prefer what he did originally
uh so you mean the one that was
submitted yes yes the blue
turquoise blue and yellow one i want to
say this as straight as possible not to
tilt the audience to lean one towards
one or the other
so the original design that was created
by blodget matthew
stephen you can't find it okay i have it
what we'll do is we'll cut back and
forth between my screen and your screen
okay
so here's the original it is
and it's full glory fully illustrated
and a lot of people say that's not a
logo that's an illustration and
it's debatable like when does an
illustration become
an icon or a logo but that's it ill
design hard to read
really funky that's original and then
mark's version here
boom black and white can you guys see
the unicorn
can you see the mane of the horse can
you read the
word mark okay a or b do you prefer the
original
or what mark did let us know in the
comments below and that was great
now thank you very much let's give him a
little let's give him a little applause
guys
there's a lot of people in the audience
today dang all right you guys are coming
in strong
okay so next yes so next up where are we
i lost my place here
all right next we're gonna talk about a
submission by bryant
seth walker brian seth walker and here's
his mark
urban pasta this is pretty cool
so davier is like into this let's let's
see what he what he's going to do with
this
or oh green all right
all right how you doing man good to see
you good to see you too
do you have a new webcam uh actually i
borrowed the computer from a friend yes
the
the camera is ready it looks really good
yes you're looking really good man okay
so let's jump in yeah
i have a video here with all my process
okay
i always try to start with some
paper
urban pasta up i get it
i know i was a little bit afraid about
the logo i chose because it's not bad at
all i mean
and i really like the idea and i chose
this logo just to give you the tweak
with the ambition
can we do this can we move the the play
button thing away from the screen
just move it down yeah move it out of
the way please further down there that's
good
great
oh yeah so you begin on paper nothing
special right no gritted paper it's just
regular old paper
yeah you'll just
just just paper with uh some pencil
anything nothing special okay
i'm curious why did you pick this of all
the hundreds of logos that have been
submitted
why'd you pick the urban pasta company
yeah that's
that was because i really liked the idea
about that the
like the noodles cross it out and
i don't know i just wanted to
to give the logo a little bit more of
with my a little more with my own vision
and something in you you will see one of
the things i decided to change
was to separate the wall mark and the
symbol
so the logo can be more flexible
okay i see so then you play
lettering but nah you're doing also
ligature there
connecting the u and the p together i
saw them when you're yeah something like
just to give like a noodle effect
and i just here i jump it to
illustrator
maybe just gonna make
more fast forward here
take me through your process what are
you thinking about doing right now here
i choose the it's something similar
to the to the original logo
i was doing like those lines
but those are like
noodles or pasta
[Music]
and you're masking it off in the circle
yeah i'm making a green
okay you give me a lot of struggles
i can see that yeah as you're working
through the problem
something like that like i can
i can make it right yeah you're trying
to get the spacing on the outside edge
to look right right
yeah yeah that's right
so then i started to experiment
a little bit with weights and
more black lines and
just like experimenting okay
and when you tried a new idea did you
just create a new artboard
yeah i don't know why i i learned it
that way
but i feel very comfortable
and not not every idea i have maybe
just like this is a big idea that can
work
by itself is separated from the rest
are you using the paste inside
shape function
did you mask it ah yeah i
mask it okay there's a new function
inside the illustrator i don't know if
you guys know but you can actually
keep objects within the shape
i don't know about that yeah i'll talk
to you about that some other time
all right
trying to figure out how to make the
logo with a
in a black in white over black
version
who siren is that is that ours yeah this
this logo is getting too hot
call the fire brigade as they say in the
uk
as you can see i can see that
it makes sense
i always wanted to try to i want to
separate different ideas
that's why i make a lot of artboards
i don't know if that makes the document
more
more heavier do you know about that
it's insignificant it's just vector it's
not going to be big
okay so maybe we should jump forward
because it looks like you're drawing the
same circle of pasta over and over again
where does this go to you
wait a minute did you just tell me to
shut up i think he just
green's like you know what shut the
front door shut the front door right now
the right words yeah whatever no i got
you a sentiment right
this is not an issue of words i get it
so you're you're curving the lines now
or you were at least
now what i'm doing is make
a smaller version with with less lines
so it can be
more legible oh okay you're trying to
simplify it yeah
okay cool and if you're not sure what
word to tell me to f off and you could
just tell aaron and he will translate
for us
[Music]
yeah it's like the same circle but just
be aware
i know all the spanish swear words so
that's
you can't you can't sneak that one on me
never never okay
no yes now uh
once the symbol was defined i started to
to
[Music]
experiment with the with type yeah it's
nice typeface
and as i said i wanted to make something
separate separated about the the symbol
and the wall mark
i also try to to modify the type to make
a custom type
using just about here
here
just to make more similar similarities
about
the u the a and the n
make it look like a noodle
nine asks what's the name of this
typeface
uh this typeface is called
alternate gothic but i didn't use that
in the end
yeah but anytime you use a typeface and
you're exploring just tell them because
they always ask during the the comments
after it's been
aired so good so alternate gothic you
said
yeah ultra catholic yeah
but i really like it that one is called
muller or mueller i don't know miller
narrow
mueller narrow okay two type faces i've
never heard of before in my life but
they look good
and i almost finished
and i do a lot of i don't know if
there are the correct term is
support graphics but
here you can see the hey wait a minute
that's just your logo man
he's trying to self-plug
okay so what are you doing now
i have i'll have some
[Music]
did you see that i'm seeing
something this is up
is this the beginning of your video
um what are you showing us man
yes i see your screen now yes okay
perfect this is the
finished logo okay here is a version
with the
with the berlin world so urban pasta
berlin that's the location
okay yeah handsome mark
some i choose the color yellow
as the same as the original
here's the symbol itself
and i made a in the corner
the smaller version yeah
and this is like the same the same thing
as the original but but with my
with apply it with the style
and more supportive super graphics i
don't know if that is the term
okay i'll buy that term
super graphics oh wait wait hold on a
second here
let me see the circular one to the
bottom left there
there's two circles right yeah um
there's
one that says there there has a like a
reverse black
circle for the berlin part
est 2017. i'm kind of digging that a
little bit
yeah okay the only problem i have with
that mark right now is that
whoa this is just trying for fun
yeah okay you keep going man yeah yeah
this is like uh what is that meditation
pasta
i thought i was tripping something like
that mm-hmm
and this is the original in my version
okay uh yeah that's
that's it okay okay so let me do you
have access to illustrator file can we
get in there i just want to look at
something
i'm going to play art director okay
now i just i want to say this okay
because i just recently got back to from
the key frames conference in orlando
and a young woman liz came up to me
she's like you know chris i have to be
honest
tending your tuck i wasn't sure i was
gonna like you if i wanted to stay
throughout this whole thing
i was taking her back a little bit i'm
like huh this is interesting
because she told me in a very honest and
vulnerable way
she said i've seen you on your show and
sometimes you can come across as
overbearing
art director i say i totally get it and
she shared her own experience with an
art director that just
really left a bad taste in her mouth so
i reminded her of that person
and so that sucks for me so now i'm like
shoot i sound like that person
and what i wanted to say is at the risk
of being an overbearing art director
let's get into it i just want to take a
look at your logo the reason why i say
this is because sometimes when you're
working on your mark
you can lose sight of like what's good
like you do so many versions
and you become attached to each and
every version so for whatever reason we
pick one or the other and sometimes
every once in a while a stranger like
myself can walk in and say huh
that's kind of interesting i like that
so can we just take a look at something
there's two things that i saw that you
did that i thought was going to work out
really well
so let's get back onto his screen
instead of my face aaron yeah there we
go
there's two things in the sketching
phase you did a mark with the u
and the p made up of several lines and
there was a ligature
i thought that would have looked really
handsome if you were to draw that
and they're like interconnected so cut
back to me aaron so you could see this
i'll draw it with my fingers right
so three stroke u like this and it cuts
across and comes
back so it's like urban pasta just to
have a different flare but
now going back to your screen the one
with the circle with the negative shape
at the bottom
inverted out let's take a look at that
can we duplicate that and work on an
alternate version
and i'll give you a critique on this one
i quite like this one
it's self-contained it will reduce down
really well it makes for good signage i
think
okay so a couple things let's zoom in
let's punch into this bad boy
so first thing that i want to say is
this is that urban pasta
is the brand name berlin and est 2017
are just the location and when it's
created right so those things are not
nearly as important as berlin pasta so i
don't think
they need to be that big generally
speaking our eye goes to the area of
greatest contrast so
right now the heaviest amount of black
is where the contrast is
so there's there's an issue with a
hierarchy potentially
i think it would be better off if you
just did the urban pasta
reversed out and reduced the size of
berlin
and esc 2017 to be much smaller can we
try to do a little live design
yeah sure let's try that yeah let's try
that and i don't i don't like the uh the
inversion of the circles and the lines
generally speaking that's not a good
design thing if you want to use black
and white
usually use in lines or high contrast
dark
drop shadows and that usually will work
really well okay
so at the risk of being that art
director guy that you guys all hate and
i hate that person too who sits over
your shoulders like you know let me do
this
my job right now is as an educator to
try to look at this and
help you guys understand if you had me
as a coach or a friend and i would look
at it and i'll give you a critique
so right now davier has done a really
great job and i just want to
explore this a little bit or oh green
i'm sorry i'm so used to calling you
javier
maybe you're just fine it's okay all
right thank you
um just let me figure out yeah you take
your time don't worry
you know the internet's watching but
don't worry it's live it's live it's
dangerous
why don't we take this opportunity to
thank our sponsors all right we don't
have any sponsors so let's read some
comments jonah
ooh not ready not ready aaron's the most
chill i've ever seen him in a long time
look at that he's casual he's like there
chilling like a villain getting it done
okay so i'll read comments too in case
jonah can't find one
okay trevin is making a joke but i gotta
go back to find his joke
was it funny oh you don't want to see
that
[Music]
no it's not you know come on let's work
on our jokes
else we got we got dead air that's what
we got
it's true it's quite okay to have dead
air it's fine be comfortable in the
silence you're right
let's just take a look at a queen
davier while he's working instead of our
faces just looking down
there we go he'll one time now we're
going to look at comments the stream
what's that let's just be silent for the
rest of the stream we could do that i
could play some music you want me to
play some music
some hot tunes all right here we go i'll
play some chill music
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
people are asking what song is this this
song is called in the sky
and it's by david absolute it's
a track available on artlist.io
a subscription platform that we belong
to that's what we're using
hey jonah i noticed the background is
crooked or is it me
whenever i straighten you out or try to
straighten you out
why can't i be straight and the
background be straight and the camera be
straight the
background isn't straight that's oh okay
we'll straighten out the background
that's the easiest thing because
i'm straight camera needs to be straight
but i'm less concerned about the
background
anyways maybe this is a bad idea you
guys because this is supposed to be only
a 30 minute episode and i didn't mean to
put
davier on the spot there like this i
thought he organized the file a little
differently
but maybe that was just too crazy to ask
that's quite all right
let's do this let's do the review let's
do the review let's show the before
and the after the a and the b so you
guys know what time it is
let's do that okay let's look at the
original which i thought was a pretty
good mark to begin with
it's simple it's bold it's graphic and i
didn't think there was a lot of room to
improve it however
i've already got into it yes we can see
okay there's some
issues with the original let's put the
original on the left please is it
possible to do that
or am i being a jerk if i say that
okay no don't worry about it i'm a jerk
just leave alone don't worry about it
okay on the right hand side is the
original
just hit pause dude all right all right
what are we doing
oh is this preview standby standing by
today's day of technology woes
you're just staying on your guy's face
someone said we both like sauce yeah i
have no idea
[Music]
does that mean like he's drunk shows up
to work drunk sauced
yeah that must be some british guy
saying that
is that a british term i didn't know
that was a british term
we say drunk here in america or plastic
yeah
wasted yeah there's many things that we
say but we don't say sauce
blimey aaron looks sourced exactly
okay i can only do the fake will
patterson
uh voice but okay
here we go before on the right hand side
urban pasta
the original it had some graphic
patterns in there
i'm not quite sure what it meant
originally but you can see the issues
that
davier was working through in terms of
the tangency between those lines and the
inner circle
there's some inconsistencies so you can
see that sometimes it looks heavy and
sometimes
there's a little white sliver stuck in
there so that took him some time to
resolve
so i think this is one of those logo
designs where it was just a little tweak
it wasn't
trying to reinvent the pasta wheel if
you will
so there it is simple pattern on the
left is the revised version
done by elgin davia lorrero urban pasta
berlin urban pasta okay
you guys let us know do you guys prefer
the original
or the new urban pasta which one would
you dine at
let us know in the comments below that
means guys that means
that means let's give them a round of
applause first of all yeah
you guys are clapping a little bit too
close to the microphone it might
pop somebody's ear and just make them
bleed a little bit well you got to bleed
for your art i think right
okay let me get out of the show i think
this is it for us right
sure is chris it is okay guys if you're
having a heavy case
of fomo fomo that's what the kids say
fomo
fear of missing out just be sure you
guys find us on facebook this is how you
find out about
events competitions and everything else
that's good and new
in the universe of the future okay
there's a thread that's
pinned i believe you guys can just go
ahead and submit your logo we're going
to just keep looking at the same
original thread and we'll pick out a
logo we have three teams
of logo therapists that will be digging
through and finding their favorite
logo to work with and they'll be
contacting you to get your
adobe illustrator or ai file and then
we'll go from there okay that's it for
our show today guys i hope you guys
enjoyed it
i will see you guys in a little bit i
believe we're coming back on the stream
at one o'clock with henry kaminsky on
our main channel we're going to talk
about click funnels conversion funnels
marketing funnels
purchase funnels all the same kinds of
things you definitely want to check that
out
guys don't forget to like comment and
subscribe thanks for watching that's it
for me thank you both you guys march
and oh green see you guys next time
bye guys i'm gonna take us out of here
with some isaac hayes
a classic
aaron what can we talk about it
cuts it out of the screen no that's
[Music]
[Applause]
great